Nick Carter confirmed he and his wife
Lauren are expecting a baby on Monday
night's episode of Dancing with the
Stars
they even learned they're having a boy
after a live TV gender reveal
et was with the happy couple after the
show I would feel to kind of finally let
you know let the world know and get the
cat out of the bag it's been a relief in
a lot of ways because I was able to
finally tell the world and say you know
what what I had been feeling and holding
inside which is you know that she was
pregnant so it was a relief for me how
excited you guys have a boy
we were hope we obviously want a healthy
baby but we were hoping for a boy
earlier in the night Nick and Lauren
revealed they previously suffered a
miscarriage was there any hesitation
about sharing your story such a personal
story on national television I didn't
want to get emotion I didn't want to cry
and I held it in all the way to the end
I was just like God like and it just
kind of all came out you know all these
different emotions from the preparation
of the dance to the story itself meaning
so much to me you know it's something
with my my wife you know all those
things kind of combined made it really
emotional for me what are you looking
forward to most about having a son
honestly yeah I look here's the thing I
knew that she'd be the best mother and
that's why I felt comfortable going to
that next step is because of her and I
know that she'll help me raise a good
boy
you